willing to continue negotiations on the
other hand the president is absolutely
prepared to defend our interests we've
already lost the trade war we don't have
a trade war we've lost the trade work
one man was younger we do not want to
fight but we are not afraid to fight a
trade war China will fight back for sure
China will respond in a new and
comprehensive way we're focused on the
long-term economic principles let's be
clear the tariffs that we're talking
about China have not been implemented in
our months away so we may take a hit and
you know what ultimately we're going to
be much stronger for it well what is
going to happen if these tariffs the new
ones are put in place and China
retaliates the Dow a little shaky on
this question today it's assume dealing
with this we as you look at the fall-off
about 760 got some back at the end of
the trading day the president has been
very open about this he's been tweeting
about it we pay attention to a lot of
his tweets this is actually a retweet of
his own tweet so we do patients pay a
special attention to this one we are not
in a trade war with China that war was
lost many years ago by the foolish or
incompetent people who represented the
US now we have a trade deficit of 500
billion a year with intellectual
property theft of another 300 billion we
cannot let this continue double tweeted
that one let's bring in our panel jonah
goldberg senior editor at the National
Review Charles Lee an opinion writer for
The Washington Post and Charles hurt
opinion editor for The Washington Times
charlie thoughts where this is headed
and if it's a collision course we're
looking at
yeah well it's certainly not something
we've seen around Washington for a very
long time but but the president is right
about this if you look back at the past
20-30 years
we have been at sort of war with China
over at an economic war whether it's
textiles or furniture they they still
you know our intellectual property as
well as our designs and things like that
they've been eating our lunch for a very
long time and it's something politicians
in both parties have
paid lip-service - and campaigned on
trying to do something about and this is
a guy who and we can all debate about
whether this is the right way to do it
or and we don't know whether he will
succeed but at the end of the day this
is something that that he probably he
won an election promising to do
something about and obviously no
politician would ever embark on a fight
like this a few months before a midterm
election but this guy is not a regular
politician Larry Kudlow and his new job
has been talking about tariffs tickle is
terrified for Prosperity killers they
always have been and they always will be
if you lower tariffs and lower barriers
and open markets and clearly follow the
laws with respect to technology stealing
this will be good for everybody
my point is tariffs enter the picture
negotiations enter the pictures the WTO
enters the picture you follow and you've
just got to walk through this process
and we'll see hopefully this will have a
very happy ending you follow this is a
negotiation he says Chuck and he'll be
on Fox News Sunday this weekend he's
been on in several shows kind of laying
this out saying it's not a done deal yet
this is part of the negotiation well
which you heard Larry Kudlow saying
there in a vague way was more or less
the line of American industry itself
particularly the high tech industries
who are very annoyed with China they are
getting hurt by China but they fear a
total blow-up and they what they're
asking of the Trump administration is to
treat the endgame here as one in which
the goal is to bring China back into WTO
compliance not what the president says
which is to get China to decrease its
bilateral deficit with the United States
so in a way Larry Kudlow there is
articulating the view of mainstream
American business but I'm not sure that
is the view of the president I think the
president is fixated on the bilateral
trade deficit I think he feels that in a
way we have the upper hand because since
we import so more we can put more
tariffs on more stuff and it it there is
a negotiation going on it's not like
will there be one and the question is
going to be will the press
except with China seems to be prepared
to offer which is a lower tariff on our
cars and maybe some of their
semiconductor market in return for
calling off those tariffs or does he
want something more
Jona the signals from China and you talk
to people who know China well suggests
that they just want to know what Trump
wants from them I mean they are so
confused it seems yeah that it's almost
like they're off their game no III think
that's right and I'm not sure it's
necessarily advantage I think a lot of
things need be separated out the
intellectual property of theft is a real
problem and that needs to be done about
it
and American business doesn't need to be
scolded for their complicity this they
complain about it but they go along with
it when they go over to China because
they want to be part of those markets
but this announcing of these tariffs now
it's kind of like that scene in the
usual suspects where Kaiser Soze it
kills his own family before he even
tries to negotiate because to the WTO a
year and a half ago at the beginning of
this and filed complaints against China
that were really aggressive on a
multilateral lines and the the the fact
is we're not all that complying with WTO
either
but China actually has a much deeper
interest in staying in good graces of
WTO and they tend to actually comply
with that stuff instead we've gone
straight to threatening the trade war
part without actually working on this
when I listen to poor Larry I love Larry
Kudlow of known Larry Kudlow for 25
years he's in this position of trying to
make this a rational thing about
negotiations about intellectual property
theft but Donald Trump has for 30 years
said that he cares about the bilateral
trade stuff he it used to be chap at
Japan and now it's China and he just has
a different economic view of this stuff
all right but let's put the concert show
so so stay away but if shaking up the
pot like he did on North Korea changes
the dynamic is that a bad thing it could
be a great thing or it could be a
terrible all right let me turn to Russia
listen to the White House press
secretary
the administration has sanctioned seven
Russian oligarchs twelve companies and
17 top government officials and a lie
of Russian President Vladimir Putin what
we all want at the end is good
relationships with Russia when it comes
to being able to have a stabilized
region region but that of course would
include that Russia does not move
forward with bad behavior we're gonna
continue working forward in what we can
to have that meeting and have a meeting
with Vladimir Putin at some point
Russian embassy putting out a statement
in reaction to these new sanctions
Washington has delivered yet another
blow on the Russian US relations now the
sanctions cover captains of Russian
business who refused to play to
Washington scenario the United States
has made yet another erroneous step to
destroy the freedom of enterprise and
competition to impair in integration
processes in the global economy let's
kind of a wordy statement from the
Russian embassy but bottom line for all
the talk this administration is pretty
tough on Russia now yeah and and it's
kind of unfortunate that it's taken this
long but I think that a big reason for
that is that that so early on this whole
issue about Russia meddle in meddling in
the election became so hotly politicized
and it and it turned into a partisan
thing where it really probably shouldn't
have been nearly as partisan as it is
and quite frankly I you know I think the
lion's share of the blame for that lies
at people who have tried to have turned
this Russia thing into a you know we're
there any way that they can smear Donald
Trump they could well what strikes me
about this is the sweeping nature the
tough nature of the condemnation of
Russian behavior they're not specifying
that it's because of the poisoning in
London or anything like that it's Russia
is generally creating mischief in the
world and that is a big statement that
is a big new orientation in foreign
policy